places still serves spiked milkshakes
They don't serve Spike root beer floats
it's not a Joe you're you're stupid I'm
not stupid that the root beer float to
me is more refreshing it quenches thirst
while it's creamy and I don't have it as
often so when I have it I'm always more
excited about it where your root beer
float's never done ain't brought nobody
to the yard and we all know that I was
hoping that you wouldn't go there but
you can get a milkshake anytime anywhere
not people don't have oh yeah it's so
hard to make a root beer float to dump
ice cream in a soda like a pig people
don't have Roots milkshakes is all I'm
saying because they suck no